je vous emmène aujourd'hui à new york
pour parler d'un smartphone qui vient
d'être annoncé par au pot savez cette
année aux points sorti plein de nouveaux
smartphones notamment la gamme raynaud
qui fait un gros focus sur la photo
alors il ya un smartphone qui bouge pas
c'est le reno a clos une fois disque et
le haut de gamme le très haut de gamme
en termes de photos celui là il bouge
pas pour l'instant il reste comme ça
mais il y avait un autre modèle c'était
le réno lorenzo lui il change il y avait
donc le réno un peu standard voilà
maintenant le réno avec succès deux pas
de faire écraser voici maintenant le
réno 2 alors je vous parle de ça à new
york non pas parce qu'il était présente
à new york
il a été présenté à londres
malheureusement je ne pouvais pas être
allons problème de changement de place
tout simplement je suis à l'événement de
google aujourd'hui pour présenter les
nouveaux pixels donc voilà je pouvais
pas y être mais néanmoins comme au pot
est très gentil et montrait gentiment de
passer envoyé raynaud 2 j'ai donc pu le
tester puis quelques jours ça avec moi
alors aujourd'hui je vais pas vous faire
un test j'ai pas vous parler du texte ou
de suite je me laisse quelques jours
plus pour mieux apprendre à
l'apprivoiser
je vais néanmoins vous le présentez vous
montrer ses qualités
et si elle vous montre un peu à quoi
ressemble ce qu'on peut faire avec qui
vous allez voir franchement ça profite
[Musique]
khalifa aux mains selon
blasco
donc je souhaite y a plus qu'à
je pense qu'il vous connaissez new york
et si vous êtes déjà venu ici d'un
landau vous avez manhattan donc new york
queen bronze
mon clean et de l'autre côté la côté de
l'hudson river vous avez le new jersey
voilà ça le new jersey c'est là bas
manhattan c'est la voilà donc je me suis
dit que je pourrais me poser si la
personne rêveur regarder elle est pas
mal on a le soleil qui se couche dans le
dos a fait des vues qui sont vraiment
très sympa je vais me poser par là j'ai
justement vous présenter ce smartphone
et puis vous dire grand chose le premier
point c'est le design on reste dans le
loup qui nous avait présenté au pot avec
son raynaud alors c'est normal on reste
dans la même chose avec ce raynaud de on
va retrouver sur la petite bille ici ce
qui fait que lorsque vous allez le poser
à plat il baissa pas venir frotter ici
ça risque pas d'endommager toutes les
caméras que vous avez à dire je sais pas
si vous voyez bien vous avez quatre
caméras de plus en plus il a de plus en
plus design for raynaud moi j'aime bien
je trouve ça assez sympa très jolie
plutôt bien fait vous avez un très grand
écran à l'avant un capteur d'empreintes
digitales up qui est extrêmement réactif
possible oui parce que quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de lumière et si moi
je le vois très très bien mais des fois
avec caméra comme ça c'est un peu moins
évident vous avez la petite caméra
aileron de requin ou qui sort qui est
juste là qui vient se planquer ce que
permet de dégager un très grand écran et
ça c'est aussi vachement cool on
retrouve ici le bouton pour venir
l'allumer et l'éteindre de la recharge
en usb c'est un micro haut parleurs ici
une prise jack et conserver les boutons
volume est bien évidemment la partie
kendra qui est là avec le petit haut
parleur bien gros focus ketef au niveau
de la vidéo sur ce smartphone vous avez
plusieurs caméras l'ariège dont déjà une
caméra de 48 mégapixels c'est la caméra
principale
[Musique]
vous avez aussi un grand angle 216
degrés
[Musique]
un tel objectif avec un zoom x 2 optique
colette masse ping et yu gi 3,5 jusqu'à
fois 20 ans numérique au bon format
numérique quand vous y arrivez qualité
c'est pas ça passe à une en tout cas sur
le principe pourquoi pas et vous avez
une lentille de 2 mégapixels qui est là
pour le mode portrait pour apporter une
fois c'est en profondeur de champ et
pour la photo de nuit vous avez le mode
nuit totale ultrasons comme vous voulez
que permettra de chuter la nuit et
surtout ce qui intéresse de chuter
lorsque vous l'avez à la main c'est pas
obligé d'avoir un trépied ça vous évite
effectivement et bien d'avoir des images
d'une façon un peu tremblotante
biya s'est créé
jouer de nos gars tu aurais fait jouer
au maire
faire l'amour
ça effectivement à se re tester d'ici
quelques jours moi j'ai déjà testé gérer
quelques photos nuit je trouve assez
intéressant et le gros gros gros gros
point positif là dessus c'est que
vraiment gros boulot qu'ils étaient
faits au niveau de la vidéo sur la
stabilisation
[Musique]
est ce que faire de folio
m
politique
dans leurs yeux
ouais pas si vous voyez bien que cette
petite icône là qui va venir à apporter
de la stabilisation vous cliquez là
dessus ça vous permet effectivement de
stabiliser toutes vos vidéos ou alors
tout ça on se testera d'ici quelques
jours
j'espère quelques plans pour l'instant
j'ai filmé de 38 ans déjà fait quelques
photos les photos se trouve ça
intéressant la vidéo ça marche bien
c'est en tout cas un pas qui franchit
une fois de plus par opole dessus l'idée
d'aller toujours plus loin en termes de
photos d'aller plus loin en terme de
vidéo parce que des video phone il y en
a quelques-uns mais c'est pas tout à
fait ça peut-être ça sera le prochain
objectif pour les grandes marques
d'aller plus loin et de proposer
réellement un vidéophone d'excellente
qualité à savoir 4 si vous avez une
double stabilisation c'était
rentabilisation optique et une
stabilisation numérique ce qui permet
aussi d'améliorer ça c'est que vous avez
un gyroscope à 800 m pour y filmer
jusqu'en 1080p à 60 images par seconde
complètement stabilisée autre point qui
est nouveau là dessus pour venir filmer
avec le mode portrait ici là avec ses
petites icônes que vous avez là seront
axés pointillés ça vous permet d'avoir
le mode portrait en vidéo avant vous
l'aviez qu'en photo on verra également
ça donnera lors du test mais sur le
principe en tout cas c'est assez
alléchant à mon avis la sortie mal pour
une personne par contre dès que vous
mettez plusieurs personnes dans le champ
j'ai peur que ce soit moins terrible une
fois de plus à mort par un lorsqu'on
fera le test pour aller plus en terme de
vidéo il faut forcément pouvoir éditer
directement dans et justement vous avez
une application lantages qui vous permet
d'éditer directement ce que vous avez et
shooter donc ça c'est assez cool parce
que si vous l'avez pas c'est un peu
compliqué il faut que vous puissiez
j'étais monté et partager directement
sur les réseaux sociaux
donc là vous à votre appli qui s'appelle
se loupe il vous permet de faire tout ça
vous pouvez ajouter vous transition
enfin vous verrez tout ça ça a l'air
assez intéressant point de vue
performances vous avez un snapdragon 730
g g pour la série gaming c'est de dire 1
730 un peu plus performants 8 gigas de
ram 256 giga de stockage et une grosse
batterie de 4000 milliards d'euros pour
tenir au moins deux jours ça
effectivement je vous le dirai aussi
lorsqu on testera dans quelques jours et
n'oubliez pas que chez au point est
toujours de la recharge rapide donc sa
smart home que vous allez pouvoir
charger extrêmement rapidement sans vous
prendre la tête
l'idée c'est que si vous êtes un peu
acrobatique vous avez oublié le charger
et par vaux mieux que le guet et vous
êtes parti pour un tour
autre point qui est intéressant c'est le
refroidissement vous avez un
refroidissement en graphite mais
également un refroidissement liquide en
cuivre donc ça c'est plutôt cool
il existe dans deux couleurs
vous avez le bleu océan et vous avez la
couleur noire lumineuse laurent tarifs
il est à 499 euros c'est ce qu'on avait
déjà avec lorenzo 1 l'aurait nos deux
restent au même tarif et il sera
disponible dès le 18 octobre au niveau
packaging on change pas une équipe qui
gagne on a toujours un peu le même look
1 au port et nos deux semaines look
blanc qui est très sympa et qui fait la
force de au pot café la consulter sur
son réseau un tu as toujours à ouvrir
ses traits à gérer à l'intérieur un plat
voyez cette petite partie avec la
documentation
là vous avez le smartphone qui se loge
ici ensuite on vient enlever ça vous
allez trouvez pas ça s'envole parce
qu'un petit peu de vent ici vous trouvez
en dessous ici votre bloc de charges que
j'ai mis ailleurs ici votre câble que
j'ai aussi mes arrière parce que je le
sache et vos petits écouteurs voilà donc
la boîte est assez sympa ça se tient
bien le smartphone est cool moi je
trouve vraiment très intéressant bien
positionné pour un photophone confirmant
sa d'ici quelques jours et n'oubliera ce
matin qu'il faut protéger c'est
extrêmement important
moi je vous conseille bien évidemment
les coques solide suite de mon
partenaire rhinochill vous reprenez
votre petit coq
vous m'enlevez l'autocollant strictement
à rien et vous le mettez directement un
paf
regardez-moi ça autour de votre
smartphone ça vous fait un smartphone
qui est très joli et que c'était carbone
et puis surtout il est protégé donc ça
ça c'est cool à bout de mediamath ans
que vous en penser comment vous trouvez
vous serez no2 voulu marquer tout ça en
bas commentaires et nous on en repart
très très rapidement en quelques jours
le temps de finaliser toutes mes photos
tous mes shoots mais vidéo et on va ça
ensemble sur ce je vous embrasse et vous
donne rendez vous dès demain
bisous ciao